hey guys sounds like we're here in Super
Bowl City in San Francisco and I'm about
to head into the Intel booths they have
a lot of really fun little activations
that you can do they have one of my most
favorite is the drone flying they have
one of these rooms that will avoid
obstacles using the realsense technology
I showed you guys that at CES so we're
gonna check it out they also have one of
these really cool things that I've also
showed you before you can get a 3d scan
of your body and have it laser etched
into the last and they have another
little setup
where you can add face paint yeah let's
head inside and then I'll take you guys
around the rest of Super Bowl City what
we're doing is we are teaching pilots in
90 seconds or less how to fly a drone
and then every hour we're demoing that
unique over here this big boy until
younger brother which now they had the
typhoon age got the realsense technology
built into it
so obstacle avoidance follow me mode it
looks really good now these drones
actually out right now for consumer
services so this is out here this is the
cute Python and the third quarter the
typhoon eh will be out which has Intel
both inside of it which is really cool
we saw it at CES it's what I'm excited
about is using real sense for the
obstinance because I have crashed my
drone many times into things so this
will help people not do that absolutely
I mean I think that's part of that the
whole reason we're here with this flight
school is that people can learn on these
tougher smaller ones that way when they
fly the bigger ones like a lot of us do
they're not just flying them into these
buildings in lovely downtown San
Francisco what you probably should not
be flying your drones downtown say which
is gone I'm just saying you probably
shouldn't be doing that yeah in fact
it's actually illegal here so don't do
that you want to fly should be raised
I'll do whatever
thankfully they're better pilots than I
am I will not be touching this one three
Oh
I've just spotted a Phil's coffee so I'm
gonna grab a copy and then continue on
our way of exploring Super Bowl City
it's cold
Gared
so I just got home from San Francisco
I'm so tired it was like a quick trip in
and out of the city and I had so much
fun meeting you guys and also somebody
brought Maddie a present
did you know somebody liked you today
look at him just looking ready go get it
go get it Maddie oh he loves it they
also bought him a cookie they brought me
a cookie as well and I already ate mine
daddy look at this this is your baby boy
you wouldn't give that amazing a lick
hope you guys enjoyed the video let me
know who you guys are rooting for in the
Super Bowl I had so much fun on Intel
today and meeting you guys and now I'm
gonna probably go to bed so yeah we'll
see you later
Thanks okay let's open you up I need to
get to the insides